let me ask you first of all about the
concept car I was just sitting in over
there it's the qat inspiration he's not
it there's a little big head for
production but what is that supposed to
broadcast look have a look at that and I
think you get a really clear indication
of what the design DNA is going to be
for the future
you know we're not too far away from two
really important product launches q30
q60 more about that at the Detroit Motor
Show but when you see those cars you'll
see that what you see in the design
lines are there have been pulled through
all of our products so what you see
there is the Infiniti look well I feel I
feel like we already got some fairly new
and maybe that's because time goes so
quickly for me some fairly new products
with the q50 here I know sebastian
vettel helped you guys design this and
even do 70 l behind me which is a
stunning vehicle how are these two
vehicles doing for you as far as sales
really well really well first of all q7
al this is the first month that we sort
of had a full pipeline so early days but
you know we expect sales to probably
triple over on a month over month basis
compared to the last generation of car
so very very strong very strong the q50
of course it's one of the core models
for infinity and the really good news on
that is it goes from strength to
strength on a month-to-month basis we're
up about 15% in sales and you know the
q50 really is the the new design
language of of infinity and already you
can see similarities between that and
the qat that you referred to at the
beginning well in the old you know the
old thought was that any kind of
sustainability any kind of green efforts
to boost mpg was gonna go I was gonna go
head-on with performance yes but you
have a hybrid version of this which
proves what we are the new thinking is
that when you make a greener car you can
actually get a more powerful forest yeah
look it's really interesting because all
the emphasis on technology is is finding
solutions to problems that nobody ever
had really before this q50 here 360
horsepower and you've got to remember
when you put an electric motor in
something you get your max
talk on first touch of the fun demands
on the land so you have a look at the f1
cars now you know we've got sebastian
federal in those cars and you're getting
the the same sort of performance you had
out of turbocharged engines you're
getting green technology but you're
getting power delivery in ways that
people didn't really think about five
years ago let me ask you about Sebastian
he was the unbeatable reigning world
champion this season hasn't gone so well
and now he's going to go over and drive
for the Italians what does that mean to
you what does that mean to the brand
look nothing stays the same forever and
he's been an incredible ambassador for
the brand much more comment on what
Sebastian's doing at the moment is
premature because you know nothing's
been formally announced but that aside
there's our friend Ricardo yeah Ricky I
know however you like to to pronounce it
and he certainly stepped up to the up to
the podium Red Bulls as strong as ever
the relationship with Red Bull the
sponsorships as strong as ever and I
think it just goes to show that this is
an incredibly dynamic industry and no
matter where federal is he'll always do
well but there is with us or anybody
else he's earned his stripes four times
world champion with infinity Red Bull
team you can't beat that
but you know one certainty things change
let's let's let's turn a little bit here
and get a look at this the q7 DL you can
see it's a much bigger car there's a lot
more room to stretch out in the back and
that has to be driven by the Chinese
market even though I'm we all enjoy
luxury you're doing well there yeah look
actually the q7 TL was not driven by the
Chinese market that was driven by the US
market but there is a queue 50 L which
was driven by the Chinese market and
this here is a car that was very much
built with the US market in mind you
know it's right up there in terms of
dimensions with the 7 Series BMWs and so
on like that but a very different price
point it sort of sits in a very nice
little leash where the other t1
competitors are not sitting from a price
point of you said there's no there's a
very much US car I think that the
Infiniti really has more of a US
and the presence in Europe isn't so huge
the presence in China hasn't been
traditionally very big but your sales
overseas are really boosting your global
the global top-line yeah look it's a
reality the Infiniti brand has been a
u.s. centric brand that we've been here
for 25 years you know we've been
representing almost 7080 percent of
global sales and the really good thing
right now as far as the the global
strategy we're starting to see the
fruits of that sales are doubling in
China we're going to get to plus 30
thousand units this year and that's
really important for the brand it's
really important for the US because
there are economies of scale but a
better mass better brand parents
presence in this global world it's all
working it's going very well